today we're going to revise logic gates
first of all and or and not let's take a
look at and first of all I'm going to
write out its so-called truth table in
my own way which might be slightly
different to the way other people lay it
out I like to lay these things out as in
a sort of square matrix
let's call here on the left input a into
my hand gate and up at the top I'm going
to talk about input B it has two inputs
and one output and the output from the
gate is represented inside this square
area so the a input we're working in
binary as ever can take on values of 0
and 1 so can be ok and is very simple
it says the outcome is true which is
normally denoted by a1 nowadays in
binary the outcomes true only if both of
the inputs are true of course that's
what hand means in English that must be
true and that must be true so let's do 1
and 1 first of all 1 1 is like true and
true yes the outcome is true but if you
take 0 and 0 given that zero means false
then the and can't be true
because you're saying is false and it's
false so the outcome is false it's a
zero and equally if one of them is true
and one of them is false the outcome
still is false because the outcome of a
NAND gate for it to be true both of them
have got to be true so you end up with a
result matrix here look with three
zeroes in it and only one one now just
this once I won't do it for all of the
others but just this once I shall say
feel free to write it down like this
with an F and a T standing for true and
false but it's still the case that under
and logic for the outcome to be true you
must have a couple of true inputs here
so that's exactly the image of that
using absentee is rather than ones and
zeroes if you're an electronics engineer
and you're building some electronics to
do these logic
Auctions what you would draw is your
hand the gate with two inputs a and B
one output and yeah thing to remember is
that the and is a fairly rounded kind of
shape at the front but the point here is
that the outcome of doing a and B
together can be written in lots of ways
you could write it as a and B sometimes
if you look in logic textbooks you'll
find that they use a thing looking like
a little spike down on the baseline that
is the mathematical logicians favorite
way of saying hand but it's the same
thing as writing a nd very occasionally
you'll also see a dot B that dot is like
the one that some of you would have been
taught at high school to denote
multiplication rather than using the
multiply symbol it was noted early on
that and is a bit like doing
multiplication because if you say what
happens if I just multiply the two
inputs instead of doing this and
nonsense well 0 times 0 is 0 1 times 0
is 0 that one must die by 1 1 times 1 is
you get the same outcome there as if
you'd be multiplying the ones and zeros
with each other and that is why and it's
sometimes called logical product okay
now we've got the notation established
we can go ahead fairly quickly now on
the other possibilities here let's take
a look at the or gate well for this
which is the so called inclusive or if
you want to give it its full name the
rule is that the outcome is true if
either or both of the inputs are true 1
inclusive or with 1 1 or 1 well they're
both true so the outcomes true 1 odd
with 0 if either one of them is truly
outcomes true you put a 1 there
similarly 0 order with one well one of
them is true so the outcome is true and
only 0 order with 0 gives you a 0 or a
false so it's called an inclusive or
because it includes
this situation here where they really
are both true to start with writing it
down in what an electronics engineer
likes to see here you come fast back go
faster tail fin there and it slips round
like this
there is your or gate with an A and a B
inputs here comes the output and again
we can either write it down as a or with
B or we could say a notice it's the
opposite way round to the and that looks
like a little V on the baseline so you
can write it like that or many people
noted very early on when studying
mathematical logic that all does more or
less behave like addition not quite I
mean look at it 0 plus 0 is 0 0 plus 1
is 1 1 plus 0 is 1 1 plus 1 ah really
referring back to the binary adder video
I did a week or two ago one added to one
should really put down a zero and carry
one but here it's as if the carry bits
retained and held inside but as far as
magicians were concerned a lot of them
like to call this the logical some
whereas and is the logical product to
complete these three those are very
familiar indeed now there is a very
special one and that's how a good old
friend not it's special in that it
doesn't take two operands it only takes
one operand naught is a simple inverter
give it a 0 it'll turn it to a 1
give it 1 it'll turn it to a 0 so we've
only got one input let's call it a
what's the outcome well the outcome is a
single column now it's not a square
because what you're saying is if you
apply not to 0 you get a 1 if you apply
not 1 you get a 0 it just flips it
simple as that and the circuit diagram
electronics e-type notation which is a
triangle with a little circle at the end
and what comes out of here well there's
lots of right ways of writing not a you
can write it as not a sometimes you'll
see it written as twiddle a sometimes
you'll see that some logicians like to
use a thing like us with a bent crowbar
to denote not so that can also be used
to call the output not a those three
taken together are what it called
logically sufficient to do anything you
want in logic and or and not taken
together dr. Harb lead blesses cotton
socks has done even more advanced stuff
with you now which I'll just mention if
you want to glue or not gate onto the
output of an or gate say so you do the
inclusive all but then the moment you
get its result you flip its direction
you turn it over instead of just taking
that and gluing it onto there you're
allowed to abbreviate by putting the
circle on the end of the or gate it
still got the a and B inputs and it's
still got an output but notice the
moment you do the all you turn it the
other way around that's what the circle
says so that is a nor gate and I know
for a fact that dr. Bagla has done that
with you in one of his videos
we'd like to thank audible.com for
sponsoring this computer file video
they've got over a hundred thousand
titles to choose from and if you'd like
to try one out for free go over to
audible.com slash computer file today
I'd like to recommend red Mars by Kim
Stanley Robinson there's been a lot of
hype recently about visiting and
colonizing Mars and Kim Stanley Robinson
really captures what this might be like
to do it feels very realistic not the
sort of utopian vision you get in some
science fiction so check out red Mars go
over to audible.com slash computerphile
try it out for free and thanks once
again to them for sponsoring this
computer file video it will be useful to
refresh our memory of how an or gate
works so that's an or gate and it has
two inputs which we'll label as a and B